while there may be fewer christmas trees
to choose from this year and when you do
find one it could cost you more than
you're used to shortages and supply
chain issues are impacting both real and
fake christmas trees kate houston
stopped by moon valley nursery which
just got a shipment of fresh christmas
trees this morning this year i'm
thinking i'm gonna i might go get a real
tree and enjoy the smell i already caved
and got the cinnamon sticks so i might
as well go all out and get the pine
jessica forsthofer is ditching the
artificial christmas tree this year
concerned there may be less to choose
from there's shortage of everything
right now so i think they're just going
to fly off the shelves on tuesday moon
valley nursery received hundreds of
fresh cut trees and will continue to
over the next few weeks friday after
thanksgiving is a big weekend for us
it definitely everybody wants to get
their tree up early and get it decorated
regional manager matthew fishera says
fires on the west coast supply chain
issues and diesel prices have all
contributed to higher prices and
shortages nationwide you have to adjust
over time with you know environmental
situations with economic situations
things along that nature but we keep we
keep adjusting and each year that goes
by we have to adjust moon valley will
offer christmas trees starting around 70
dollars the average price across the u.s
last year was 81 dollars the american
christmas tree association says
artificial tree prices have gone up 20
to 30 percent this year with all the
different changes economic and
and logistical changes you know grab
your trees early because you know at
some point we will be sold out kate
houston live local now